عرف بعراب معاهده ستارت النوويه واليوم
يهدد بنسفها ويتحدث عن نهايه نوويه للعالم
نتحدث هنا مشاهدينا عن نائب رئيس مجلس
الامن الروسي ديمتري ميدفاف صاحب
التهديدات النوويه الذي يتسلح كل مره
بالعقيده الروسيه التي تقول بان دستوره
بلاده شرع استخدام النووي للدفاع عن
الدوله والاراضي الروسيه طبعا وعنده اي
تحرك غربي تجاه اوكرانيا سواء كان لدعمها
عسكريا او ماديا وحتى معنويا تتصدر من
جديد
تهديداتف النوويه ليؤكد بان استخدام
النووي ليس خدعه شغل سابقا منصب رئيس
روسيا الثالث من عام 2008 الى عام 2012
ليشغل فيما بعد رئيس وزراء روسيا العاشر
وخلال فتره حكمه نجح هذا الرجل بتوقيع ما
هو معروف بمعاهده ستارت لتخفي الاسلحه
النوويه بين كل من روسيا والولايات
المتحده هذا الامر طبعا طرح تساؤلات من
قبل المراقبين حول تطرف اراء تجاهها
تصعيده ودعمه الدائم لبلاده لاستخدام
النووي منذ بدء الحرب على اوكرانيا وحتى
هذه اللحظه اللافت ايضا بان تهديداته
النوويه لا ينشرها فقط على تطبيق تيليجرام
بل ايضا ينشرها على منصه تويتر الغربيه
كما نشاهد هنا باللغه الروسيه مما دفع
المراقبين الى التساؤل لماذا لا يتم حظر
حساب حتى هذا اليوم بسبب دعوته لحرب نوويه
بل وان حسابه كما نشاهد هو موثق بالعلامه
الزرقاء او العلامه الرماديه في اشاره على
حساب حكومي او رسمي
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات